well good afternoon it is such a great
privilege to be at a university where we
have on our faculty to former heads of
government and it's a great pleasure to
engage them both today in a conversation
about the state of the world ernesto
zedillo is a graduate of the yale
economics department went on to many
distinguished positions in mexican
government and ultimately to be the
president of mexico from 1944 1994 her
to 2000 woof he's any-any a child that
was Spain actually where the guy was
from lasted that long but so president
Sadie will return to Yale after his
tenure as president to lead the Yale
Center for the Study of globalization
former Prime Minister Tony Blair served
as we know with distinction as the
British Prime Minister for a decade and
he and he followed his funds the sun's
footsteps to Yale and came to take on
the position as the Howland
Distinguished Fellow and to lead the
program in faith and globalization and
as you know has been teaching a course
on that subject here both last year and
this year and he'll be back again next
year to continue with with with that
endeavor it's interesting a minute we're
going to have try to run this like a
conversation and it's interesting to
note that both of these great world
leaders were attracted to spend some of
their time in the academic world after
their period of leadership because the
subject they wanted to reflect upon was
globalization in both cases and both are
concerned that the benefits of
globalization be widely disseminated and
that the threats to globalization the
the threats that might dissipate or
destroy those benefits should be
confronted thought about analyzed and
and taught and in one respect of prime
minister blares main concern has been
the threats that religious divisive
pneus cultural divisive pneus based on
religious ideology might be front and
center in undermining the benefits of
globalization professors a deal has
focused on a number of issues but in
particular on the potential that
economic nationalism and and the
national economic policy is the
inability to agree on a global
regulatory system and financial
architecture might undermine the
benefits of globalization so I'd like to
start the conversation by engaging them
both on those central top those topics
that are central to their own thinking
about a globalization and central to the
reason that they're here so Tony let's
start with you and talk tell us a little
bit about your your thinking and how its
evolved as you've led this course here
at Yale about how does religion pose a
threat to globalization and what can be
done about it festival rate can I just
say what a thanks to Yale for giving me
the opportunity to to teach a class here
it's been an absolute honor and
privilege and the students have been a
joy to work with so thank you all very
much indeed for giving me that chance
and it's also great to be reconnected
again with Ernesto who's somebody I have
a huge admiration for hundred a
fantastic job as president and who I
used to learn a lot from when I was
starving in office look my view is very
simple that that the 20th century was a
century of political ideology capitalism
versus socialism communism fascism I
think those arguments have largely been
now resolved into quite a narrow
framework between left and right which
is not to say when still of Republicans
and Democrats but it won't and the same
ideological impulses of a political
nature that dominated the 20th century I
don't think that's going to be the issue
in the 21st century 21st century I think
the big issue is open versus closed in
other words with this force of
globalization as changing people's lives
changing economy societies are people
open to its possibilities or do they
close down in the face of it into that
and paradigm if you like open versus
closed comes the issue of religious
faith
religious faith as a phenomenon is not
diminishing which people thought it
would a lot of people used to think in
the West as people became better often
became more enlightened religious faith
would diminish it isn't diminishing
religion is actually growing in the
world but in all parts of the world but
overall it is growing religion can be a
force for good or it can be a force for
ill we see religion in many of the
conflicts that dominate the world today
and there it is a force for extremism
and an ill in what I do out in the
Middle East I see this many times but it
can also be a force for enormous good
there are people that do extraordinary
acts of selflessness in the cause of
others through religion so a large part
of the health infrastructure in Africa
is delivered by faith groups so it can
be a force for good or for ill my
question is this and this is the the
question because I think you need an
academic basis to answering this
question as well as simply a practical
basis is how do we design the policy and
what is the right framework within which
these issues to do with religion and
politics can be resolved and how do we
make religious faith a source of
progress for peaceful coexistence rather
than a source of division and conflict
and I think that is one of the big
issues of our time it's an issue that in
a practical sense I have to deal with as
a political leader and now I can come to
the more contemplative and reflective
atmosphere of of Yale and try and get
educated that's really what it's about
for me and where do you see this where
are the signs of real hope and progress
here when we're in what areas of the
world do you think that there could be
gains made in international relations or
in intra national conflict by working
with religious groups and bringing faith
groups together I mean what would it
what's the main area of focus for you
well I think the interesting thing is
that there are people right round the
world now who are trying from their
different faiths perspectives to engage
with each other learn about each other
and work out how they counter those
forces of reaction and division within
each faith and that can pull people
apart so you know what
my office out in in Jerusalem is right
on the division between East and West
Jerusalem so you in the morning early
morning you get awakened by the mosque
you look out of the window and you see
on the other side in West Jerusalem and
you know the Orthodox Jews going about
their business and there you are with
this intense religiosity in in the holy
land in Jerusalem and you realize that
in this confined space it's like a kind
of microcosm of the world if you like in
this confined space people of different
faiths different cultures unless they
can learn to respect each other not just
tolerate each other but respect each
other live with each other we will never
get peace so I think the hopeful thing
is that amidst all the conflict and
division there are people within each
religious faith calling upon their own
Scripture and they're in history to say
actually what motivates us is religious
people is some sense of compassion
social justice common humanity rather
than some source of identification of me
with my religion against you with yours
so look you know I was breeze Prime
Minister for 10 years you've got to be
an optimist I said but actually in the
end I am optimistic because I think
within the human spirit religion at its
best answers something that is in fact
the human spirit at its best so drawing
upon time just I really am struck by the
similarities and what motivates the two
of you because you're really saying that
the hope is to draw upon the positive
elements in religious faith that the
compassion for others the empathy for
others and so in other words being open
to the views of others is a crucial
element in using religion as a tool for
good and it's so interesting because i
think is I Nestor when I go back a long
way he took my economics course in his
first year in graduate school he's not
that all but but you know for so long
you've been an advocate for economic
openness rather than closing the support
for
four nations opening up to the world to
foreign investment in trade and and as
opposed to closing off how serious a
threat do we have now in this respect to
the benefits of well I think the threat
is very serious Rick we have gone
through a sort of golden age of
globalization again because we had other
eras of great globalization in the for
example in the second half of the 19th
century and yet that was over that was
finished with the outbreak of the first
world war at the time it was your
political reasons partly caused by
religious rivalry's in a way and other
factors and that eventually destroyed a
globalization and well we recover after
the Second World War Drake human cost in
between and since the end of the Second
World War progressively we have had this
increase in integration which I think
has brought significant prosperity and
in a way has also been a factor of
international peace and stability well
some people thought that this time
around this globalization was not in any
way or could not be destroyed well
actually over the last year we have got
the sense that it could happen again the
crisis that erupted with enormous force
in the fall of 08 really at some point
could have become a total collapse in
the financial system in the economic
system and put up cause dramatic
disintegration since we hadn't seen in
many decades well now we know the thanks
to the aggressiveness of economic policy
to some degree of international
coordination the worst has been avoided
but in a way we can say that the risks
of a major disruption of globalization
has been left behind and what is a big
challenge I
the big challenge is that in order not
only to fully overcome this crisis but
also to be able to retake economic
growth but without going to business as
usual that is to say to go back to the
global imbalances that put us in the
first place we will need an immense
degree of international coordination and
cooperation there is no way the u.s. can
a boy to go back to huge current account
deficits and to borrow a lot of money if
those that provided those resources in
the previous years to the u.s. don't do
something with their economic policy too
so you need agreement you need
coordination you need synchronization
this is not to say that everybody has to
do the same at the same time but we need
to have some basic understanding not
only about macroeconomics but also about
financial regulation well what is the
problem the problem is that domestic
politics for good reason because when
you have ten percent rate of
unemployment people feel bad and people
start thinking well why are we tolerate
in the Chinese to export so much you
know why are we tolerate in other
countries to take jobs from this country
why are we aren't we why should we
worried about others and so on and so
forth so the problem is that domestic
politics can run against international
cooperation so this is going to be the
big predicament or leaders in the years
to come how to explain to people that it
is in our interest to be coordinated to
cooperate I try to find common solutions
for common problems that cannot be
addressed by individual countries alone
and in my view if we are not capable of
generating this international
cooperation then I think that
globalization could be in very serious
trouble so so what's the vehicle for
this kind of coordinate is that the g20
is it some redefined
international financial institution of
some time well I think this hat this has
to start at the level of national
leadership you know because let's say
President Obama Prime Minister Brown and
president Sarkozy president calderón
president Lula go to the g20 well it's
not just to sit down there is because
they are willing and they understand
that we need this international
cooperation but they go there not only
to exercise leadership is obvious the
people that are seated there but the
most difficult part of the job is to
explain to their own people that it is
in their self-interest enlightened
self-interest to give something so that
problems which are common to everybody
can be addressed and this is very tough
because if you look at President Obama
well every day he has dramatic pressures
I mean with this rate of unemployment it
is very hard to to avoid the kind of
domestic politics that we are seeing
here and all of those forces run against
what he probably wants to say and needs
to say i need to do needs to do busy
bees that international fora so you need
enlightened national leadership but you
also need you know good international
leadership or leaders go there commit
themselves and then go back home to do
the homework which is a very tough
homework you think that's good recipe
Tony yes I think the single most
difficult thing at the moment is a
political leader is what I would call
the the clash between the correct
short-term politics and the correct
long-term policy because the short-term
political pressures are all pushing
people towards closing down
protectionism you know you look after
yourself actually the only sensible
long-term policy is to do 10 Nesta was
saying and to try and make sense of
globalization and ensure that that you
get the right coordinated policy to make
it work properly but here's the thing
that I think is really important about
this and this is what I came to
understand i think really owned only
over time I think with globalization the
only way it works in the end is if it's
imbued with some sense of justice you
know the problem is is very eat what
you're asking people to do is to open up
to the world right and you're asking
them to do so in in circumstances which
the world is a very uneven and unjust
plays you know unequal certainly and the
question is how do you persuade people
since the only way the world is going to
prosper as if it does remain open how do
you persuade them to accept that now
it's all very well for us in the tops of
our societies in the West to say well
globalization is a great thing but
actually for many millions potentially
billions of people in the world they
look at globalization and they ask for
what what is it yeah what's it going to
do for me so I think the thing is this
is to build upon ernesto say what is
important is not just to get that
coordinated policy but to get it in such
a way that we start to realize you have
got to have a policy towards
globalization that is then trying to
inculcate globalization with some form
of values and justices right at the
heart of it when i did the g8 in 2005
and even then we started to invite
Mexico and Brazil and China India some
because we could see that the world was
changing we put at the heart of that I'm
Africa and global poverty in africa and
the reason for that i mean i remember
had the debates at the time people said
well this is a great social cause we
understand it's very important you got
all these poor people in africa it's
very sad let's help them and i was
saying there is a huge reason of
self-interest why we should be taking
this action and because unless that that
almost 1 billion people in africa start
to see in the end that they have some
advantage in globalization they will end
up resisting this process and they will
end up becoming a force of reaction
against us in the West
I think you know this this question open
versus closed how do you make it work
whether it's in religious faith or it's
an economic policy I think that is the
central you know political question of
our time and it's a very tough one for
political leaders and this criteria that
Tony has is playing so well applies not
only to those countries that have been
left on the sidelines of the
globalization as many in Africa but I
think it also applies to many citizens
of the developed countries of the
countries that have got to be rich to a
greatest thing Thank thanks to
globalization but it so happens that
inside the United States and inside the
UK inside any other rich countries there
are people that are on the sidelines of
globalization that are not only in the
sidelines that may be threatened in
their situation professional or whatever
by globalization so I think governments
do have the responsibility to help those
people not in the sense of giving than a
blank check you know I pay you whatever
damage globalization causes upon you but
rather how do you equalize opportunities
for those people in terms of education
in terms of the training in terms of
some social safety nets otherwise those
peoples all those people almost by
definition are going to be adversaries
of globalization but the problem is that
if that becomes a too strong political
force against globalization somebody
else and the majority of people in
societies will be affected so you better
compensate them and support them so they
are not a force against globalization
one of the audience questions actually
picks up on the point is made about
Africa to want to ask you given the
tremendous emphasis you put on poverty
eradication and health improving public
health in Africa one are you dismayed by
the recent sort of slippage in terms of
it aid that's going to Africa and what
can be done what can be done to
actually turn that around accelerate and
where the opportunities to improve the
way that the welfare well-being of
Africa can be brought up by assistance
from the developed world and I think
actually do another part of my political
afterlife as it were I I do and projects
in Africa which are about governance and
so what we do is we get teams that we
bring in teams of young people and we we
interact alongside the president we do
this in a wander in Sierra Leone where
we're about to do it in Liberia and and
basically we try to build capacity in
those countries and here is again
something I learned from my time in
office I mean I think it's important
that we keep to our aid commitments and
I think it's a shame if we if we start
to diminish the commitments we've given
because that will be seen as a breach of
faith by those African countries but I
also think this that in the end the most
important ambition for any African
country is to get to the point where
they waved goodbye to the donor
community and in fact that the solution
for Africa is lies as much in the realms
of governance and capacity in acting
against corruption in making sure that
you have democratic sustainable
political systems in making sure that
you have the right business environment
to attract private investment actually
some of the bet worst trade barriers in
Africa are between African countries
themselves not between Africa and the
outside world and so I think it is a
combination of the help from the outside
but in the end one of the most exciting
things that's happening in Africa day is
a new generation of African leaders who
kind of want to do it for themselves and
in the end that is the best way to do it
and when I was in Rwanda just a short
time ago and I was driving around that
killed galleon actually seeing in Gilgal
either the enormous amount of a private
sector enterprise that was coming there
and we just opened a big initiative to
get more
you know investment into the country I
thought you know it's when you see that
younger generation of Africans deciding
to take the reins of power into their
own hands and their own destiny in their
own hands that we really get somewhere
there so I think it's important that we
keep up that you know that commitment
from the outside but one of the things I
I learnt during my time in office is
that actually spot some of these country
need as much as aid is good governance
mm-hmm it wasn't it wasn't foreign aid
that finally got the Indian economy
going in 1991 it was domestic will
political leadership and reform yeah for
example yeah so both of you at another
interested that are shared by by our two
professors is a an interesting climate
change and that's there had a major
conference here a couple of years ago
about the debate on optimal policies for
to remedy global warming Prime Minister
Blair has been active in working with a
number of countries and their
preparations for the Copenhagen
conference here we are Copenhagen is
shall we say warming up and hopefully
won't get overheated I think they should
treat you with respect as the president
this should be polite laughter of that
joke it's Yale we're tougher critics
right so prognosis what's going to
happen and where we going to go from I
mean what kind of agreement are we
likely to get in Copenhagen and where
will that lead us you are very good at
casting the future time no well Rick
knows my my my position which is derived
from the analysis that more
knowledgeable people that may have
produced precisely at this university
load our house great thinkers
fortunately here and I have been all
along pessimistic about the likelihood
of getting an agreement an international
agreement
that somehow tries to take the basic
features of the Kyoto agreement and try
to make it for a longer term in my view
trying to negotiate a global cap and
trade agreement is a global
impossibility by trying to negotiate a
meaningful I mean a binding effective
global cap-and-trade I think it's not
really possible because once you are
doing that that is to say trying to defy
a global cap and and undivided among
countries and you need everybody to be
somehow on board then that sort of
becomes a zero sum game and it is a game
or as a program that has a that that has
no solution unfortunately all along the
emphasis has been on getting commitments
towards quantitative targets with the
idea that once you adapt all those
individual commitments you will have a
global commitment that will match what
the scientists are telling us that
should be reasonable to avoid a higher
probability of dangerous increase in in
average temperature in the world well
unfortunately the negotiation has not
been like that I don't think we are
going to get a good effective agreement
in Copenhagen in the sense that was
ambition by people that pursue that
Avenue of negotiation few years back and
recently but I think we are going to get
important elements that in a way will
constitute a first important meaningful
step with a longer-term view for the
solution of this problem so my guess is
that
in a few years countries will have to
come back and try to build on what will
be achieved in Copenhagen I think we
will see progress but we will not see
the kind of progress that some people
would like to look right now to say now
we have a solution we can have peace of
mind that we are not in the trajectory
of doing what it takes to control global
emissions I don't think we should be as
optimistic as that but I think we should
be ready to be you know to look with
some satisfaction to the effort that I
am sure will be put intensely next week
and it will deliver not the perfect
agreement but some think that it's a
base to build upon I agree with the
conclusion i'm actually surprised to
find in this case you even more
pessimistic than I about how much will
get done this time Nick stern whose idea
of what how much needs to be
accomplished in terms of the pace of
carbon reduction actually said just the
other day that he thinks the sum of the
national commitments that are being
offered actually are very close very
close to being on track for what's
needed to keep global temperatures from
rising two degrees that was a I thought
fairly optimistic assessment of what's
going on you know we may turn out better
than we think it clearly won't get all
resolved at this meeting in the you know
the developing countries clearly are not
willing to pick yet very aggressive
targets partly because of what you were
saying earlier about a sense of justice
the sense that these are countries that
have not yet had the opportunity to
develop as much as the Western that they
ought to they ought to have a little
room to grow before the caps have to
impinge them what's your sense of
welcome it's a this is a really tough
political challenge isn't it because the
the the central thing to bear in mind is
that the difficulty with a global deal
is you're marrying together two worlds
that completely different stages of
development so am China and India
are to undergo rapid industrialization
of the next 10 or 50 years they're not
going to sacrifice that
industrialization because that is their
route out of poverty for their people so
they've got to transfer hundreds of
millions of people from poor subsistence
farming I mean in China about sixty
percent of the population is engaged in
farming now in your economy in the u.s.
is what a four percent revisited let's
chill yeah to which same as us in Europe
so that you just think about the change
and think about the fact that in in in
China they if we shut down all the
emissions in the UK so we were many am
zeno co2 emissions at all the rise in
Chinese emissions would make up the
difference in 18 months so just to get
it in context I mean China is about a
builder the next a few years more power
stations and most of which will be cold
fired because that's the cheapest source
of energy for them then the whole of
Europe put together since the Second
World War so you know and then India is
going to come behind that so this is
this is the difficult and the question
is how is a nest oh absolutely rightly
says how do you therefore in a rather
what I can send people about copenhagen
is don't make the best the enemy of the
good look at the problem being a
political leader and I think both of us
have tried to avoid this not our ways is
is you know once you've been in office
you should never after you leave office
forget how hard it was in office so I
was telling my class a couple of a
couple of seven years ago you know the
when you're a political leader like you
you're the recipient of a lot of advice
okay much of it someone solicited right
most of it unsolicited most of it after
you receive it you wish you hadn't but I
was telling them about the very fragile
shouldn't really say it's a bit naughty
but it was at the very first labor
leaders guy called Keir Hardie started
off the Labour Party was desperate to
break into parliamentary system and this
was before women's suffrage and the pan
curse who led the great campaign and in
favor of women's suffrage they were they
were obviously campaigning for Keir
Hardie to take up the cause of women but
one of the panko sisters had also done a
study on what was wrong with British
society and are described the main part
of the problems to the sexual
misdemeanors of men so she wrote to ke
ha d and this said said that he should
campaign on the slogan of votes for
women and abstinence for men Keir Hardie
wrote back this beautiful elegant letter
to her saying thank you very much for
your advice the electoral propensity of
which are not immediately discernible
and you know so take what I'm about to
say now about what they should do in
Copenhagen with mindful of the fact it's
very easy what from the outside to
preach to those who've got to take these
decisions but my view is actually this
and it echoes something in the nest as
just said the truth is our knowledge of
the science and technology is going to
change dramatically over the next year's
therefore the most sensible thing now is
to set the world on a different path and
even the accumulated commitments that
are being made now especially if you can
improve them someone but even those
accumulating commitments add up to a
significant switch in direction so
sometimes in Europe people say to me
well President Obama's got a promise
more than he's doing it and I say to
look he's about to make a commitment to
2020 which is massive in American terms
so you know it's all very well for us to
stand on the outside and say why don't
you do more but actually even that is
going to imply a major switch in your
economy towards a low-carbon path now I
think therefore what we should do is get
the best we possibly can in Copenhagen
and then accept that a few years down
the line you're going to have to review
those commitments and see if you can
expand them in the light of the science
and technology that you will develop and
one further thing I think is really
important there's no look there's no
point in denying this as a result of the
financial crisis
climate change has not altered as an
issue but it has altered in the minds of
the public as a priority somewhat you
know let's not say to everyone but I
mean let's not be unrealistic about this
and my view is I have always said about
the climate change question there are
reasons sensible reasons to do with the
environment for making this change
because even should the science prove
halfway right it is still definitely
worth taking action as on the
precautionary principle at least but
there are reasons today of energy
security that every bit as important and
the fact is you know your country my
country we get our sources of energy
often from highly unstable parts of the
world it is in our own self-interest as
a matter of energy policy quite apart
from the environment that we try and
move towards a low-carbon future and I
think it's possible to take that step in
Copenhagen and if we get an agreement in
coping in which i think it is possible
to do even if it is based really on the
accumulated commitments already given we
should not be an under any doubt that is
a hugely significant political
achievement and will require itself a
massive amount of political will to
implement very good let's shift to
another subject last year when we had a
conversation like this right here in
this very Hall Barack Obama had just
been elected president of the United
States and I asked you Tony what what
kind of advice you would give to an
incoming president about America's role
in the world and you answered that your
advice to President Obama was that he
should listen and he should lead and you
expanded on exactly what you meant by
that at the end of nearly a year in
office I'm taking seriously you're
you're you're warning that you don't you
don't like to make easy criticism of
people sitting in office that's still I
think everyone be interested in your
views of how do you how do you think
President Obama has done
in the foreign policy domain in his
first year well I think an example of
listening would be the Cairo speech
where he reached out to the Islamic
world and I think an example of leading
is what he's just decided in respect of
Afghanistan so look these are these
challenges are really really difficult
to overcome but i think he is he is
trying to see to get the right balance
between listening and leading and it's
you know it's it's an interesting round
around the world to see you know there
is a great desire for America to reach
out and to listen but as I said this
time last year in my view hasn't hasn't
changed and it is the destiny in a sense
as well as the responsibility of America
also to lead and so you know I think it
was important than personally I think it
was extremely important in Afghanistan
that he made that commitment but you
know the the the the the trouble is as
you know as I've often said to people
that the decisions that that the modern
political leader is called upon to K our
decisions that all must necessarily
impact their own country but the
problems cannot be resolved simply by
their own country even America on its
own today cannot solve some of these
problems and I think and this is what I
say to people in Europe you know it's
great to be a cheerleader for President
Obama and to give him you know high
ratings and all the rest of it but when
he actually needs help and partnership
it would be good to step up and give him
it too because he needs that frankly
more than he needs the praise he needs
the partnership and so I think that he
is you know yeah I think he's he's shown
in that sense his ability to evolve a a
view of America that is engaged in the
world and listening and leading I think
he has done that I see as a moderator an
opportunity for the first time this
afternoon to drive a wedge between these
two good friends because they're nesto
you smiled when
uh Tony gave the example of the Cairo
speech but frowned when he mentioned
Afghanistan what do you think you are
being a little bit too perverse I think
playful that's all no no no no let me
give you the story of that when I first
came here the first assignment that I
was given was to come exactly to this
place it was a commemoration of the
second I mean 911 2002 and there were
two undeservedly I was put in the same
panel with to distinguish a professor's
professor Kagan and professor goddess
and I don't know what was the topic was
your politics but we ended up having a
rather heated debate they against me and
me against them on the question of Iraq
that was the issue needless to say they
were highly supportive and I was very
worried about that possibility this was
911 Oh to my little smile was because of
that so that's why you are trying to but
you want to achieve that I think that
was def they see you guys president I
think the most difficult thing is that
these these questions though the foreign
policy questions I think are you know
they call for I mean it's one of the
reasons why i'm interested in the
academic issues to do with religious
faith and globalization I mean they call
for a a different intellectual and
conceptual framework than the ones that
we've been used to in in foreign policy
I mean they really are complicated
difficult questions and what President
Obama
is finding and will find is that as
those decisions are taken you know
they're necessarily are divisive I'm
afraid they it's it's it's tough I am
imagining you can express this better
than me you addict we were we were once
talking at something together and an
ester was talking about the difficulties
political leadership and doing the right
thing and you had a great way of
describing when you when you knew when
you were at your most proud of doing the
right thing even though this was an
economic policy it was immensely
difficult to do so and that you should
well you remember it no no this is
another anecdote and you know how it
skillful he is to change topics but it's
great no no no I think I once mentioned
to to Tony that when I left office an
acquaintance of mine came and say look I
have this graph of your I don't know how
you call it to approval by the public or
popularity whatever and when you left
office you were almost seventy percent
he said you know you should be proud and
I saw the graph and went back to April o
95 four months after i have taken office
and my approval was lower than mexico's
rate of inflation no it was true true
absolutely true and it was very logical
because i have to increase fifty percent
the value-added tax I have to make a cut
in government expenditure of almost
three points of gdp I have to increase
prices of gasoline I mean I have to make
this very difficult things because
that's what the economy needed to avoid
an even major disaster so I told my
friend you say well you know you know
when I was really proud to be President
not Mexico when my popularity was lowest
because that's when I sense that i could
make a little difference by taking this
Jones and taking all the heat that had
to be taken to address that very
difficult situation and I think that you
know you don't is very nice to be a
leader when things go nice and people
you know applauded I think the real
leaders are when when things are not
like that you have to take top decisions
in the solitude of your heart and your
office and say this is what I after
having listened to the solicited and all
the unsolicited advice this is my
decision this is my responsibility and
I'm going to do it and and you know why
not my leaders and mentors has been also
tony blair because he has faced that
situation and you know and that's why we
there is no the wish I respect
everything he has decided he knows why
he has decided that well you know the by
the way if you don't know the history of
the modern Mexican economy the
courageous and tough moves that
presidents idea took in 1994-95 panned
out and worked and there was a dramatic
recovery and the economy turned around
and and has been in much better shape
ever since so it's a was a major
accomplishment so these two gentlemen
just demonstrated why they're such great
politicians because they obviously
suggest successfully ducked my my
attempt to engage them more deeply
in the question of Afghanistan I should
be their gracious host but I'm going to
build i'm going to play the role of
slightly more aggressive moderator yeah
so explain to me here's that here's the
thing that I find paradoxical about
Afghanistan compared to Iraq if you
think about whatever you think about the
the pro or con are going into Iraq there
was at least a colorable case that Iraq
might be made into a modern nation and
that if one could make it into a modern
democratic nation in the middle in the
heart of the Middle East that that would
have a dramatic signaling effect on the
rest of the Middle East and so would be
a big gain to u.s. foreign policy to the
hotel and and really just stability in
global stability if if you if if we
truly could succeed or can succeed in
building a modern democratic state in
Iraq it's hard for me to see that that
one that's even remotely feasible in
Afghanistan and even if it were
accomplished that would have the kind of
spillover benefits that you get from
building a democracy in the heart of the
Middle East I mean Afghanistan is an
isolated place historically uncover
nabol and it's hard to see any kind of
dramatic spillover effects occurring
there so why are we investing so heavily
in stabilizing Afghanistan well we had a
pretty big spillover effect from
Afghanistan here at America we did yeah
as people are in Pakistan now yeah but
here's the thing that this is this look
this is my view you know sometimes
people say to me well it's not
Afghanistan it's it's Pakistan you
should worry about someone else says
Iran actually is what you should worry
about and you could add to that Somalia
you could add to that yebin you can add
to that Lebanon or Palestine and you
could add to that the Mindanao to speed
in the Philippines look this easily okay
Henry that's the problem the problem is
that that you see I just fundamentally
do not believe that people in
Afghanistan left to themselves wouldn't
be perfectly happy to elect their
government and to have a proper system
of government there what you've got in
these different parts of the world is a
deliberate attempt to d stately
stabilize those countries often from
influences that are driven as much from
externally as internally and look the
whole purpose of my course here and what
I'm doing with mouth my foundation is
because I believe that hard power itself
is not enough to resolve these questions
and you need education you need
interfaith exchange you need dialogue
you need nations and religious faiths
coming together and understanding but
you also need to make it clear that
where people are confronting the will of
the not just the international community
but the will of the people in these
countries by violence and terror you're
prepared to stand up to it because
otherwise what are we actually saying
because it's so difficult they should
just be left with with in this case the
the Taliban Afghanistan in the early
1960s had a GDP per head not much
different from Portugal's Afghanistan
was a country-made lightless it wasn't a
country whose people desired to be in
this situation and one of the things
that I think is most damaging about the
way this whole debate is gone in the
west over the past ten years now you
know to share my own responsibility for
it is is this idea somehow that when we
talk about freedom and democracy in the
rule of law that these are kind of
Western values you know now if only we
had a greater understanding of different
people we'd understand that people in
these different parts the world don't
really they don't care about all that
it's not true they care about it who
would choose booze there's never been
two democracies that have gone to war
right and as far as I know there's never
any a country there's been a democracy
that's chosen by the will of the people
to become a dictatorship these are
values of the universal values of the
human spirit
they're not Western values and where
people have got the chance to take those
values and use them to create their
country our job in my view is to stand
alongside them and to support them and
not to desert them in their hour of need
and in an interdependent world as we
have found with Afghanistan a problem
there does not stop there it came in the
end to us and that's why we're there and
that's why might be we have to see it
through
I got an answer that was great thank you
that's the shifting gears once again to
a an area that I think audience would be
interested in you both had distinguished
careers as leaders you've both chosen to
spend part of your time and in Esther's
case all of his time at at a great
University presumably because you have
some faith and confidence that the
mission of an institution like this is
actually going to contribute something
important to society you know as you
reflect upon your role in the University
and you're an your role as as leaders in
the world what what what are the what
should we be doing what are the
competencies that we should be seeking
to instill in young people to make them
future citizens and future leaders what
what what what could what can we be
doing what are we doing now and what
could we do better to encourage
leadership and and prepare people for
leadership is the expert okay you are
working yeah I'm working but I look I
tell you from buffer I don't know what I
think of this but the thing that I would
I used to get a bit frustrated as a
prime prime air I got 40 so for many
reasons of prime minister but but I used
to get frustrated sometimes when I
didn't feel that the academic
institutions were giving me enough of
the intellectual and I don't necessarily
mean the answer but actually even the
right discourse about the issues that
matter one of the things that I think is
really important for the world of
academia is always to understand that
the best academic thought is the thought
that leads to practical effect of action
now I think actually able does do this I
think you're the whole concept is is is
right here but that's what what we need
the thing is you know with political
leaders I mean they are when all said
and done believe it or not human beings
you know
they are still earthlings but people
kind of don't think of us like that you
know they think is if you've right you
just put down in that spot as the
political leader of a country and you
know you get there all the advice and it
all comes in in the right way and all
the rest you're there trying to grapple
really difficult problems you're
searching for ideas you know so I think
the role of the academic institution is
to provide the stimulus and the
creativity and the innovation
intellectually and conceptually one of
the things that you know you know I used
to say to my people the whole time is is
the politics believe it or not and
people don't think of it like this
politics is an intellectual business it
really is I mean you know these when he
was dealing with it i wish i had seventy
percent approval ratings were down the
left office but but you know he couldn't
do what the economic crisis in a vacuum
had to work it out you need a conceptual
framework so I think the best thing that
we can ask from you is is to realize
that the we are actually believe it or
not aware of our own fallibility and
need support and help and this isn't a
really changing world you know when you
were telling me about behavioral
economics the other night and how it
developed as a field I mean that
developed quickly right but there are
politicians today who are owned by being
the concepts of that and using it to
formulate poppin and whether right or
wrongly but is the in formulate policy
now that is the right relationship might
be between the academic in the in the
bleeding world hmm yeah i agree with you
i will just add because now that i see
Peter Salovey there I remember that once
he forced me to think a little bit about
I mean how I interpreted what this
university at least in my experience and
gave students in contrast to what other
universities
try to give and of course we always have
the reference in Cambridge Massachusetts
you know hard work where they say well
we bring a students here to make up them
leaders and that's a very synthetic way
to express it and I was thinking about
my experience here Sam well I you know
when I came here I didn't sense that my
professors wanted to wanted me to learn
how to be a leader I I don't recall that
word being repeated but I think they did
something more more important which
really mark my life and that of others
that were classmates at mines or came
later and one thing was that somehow we
learn or we were in steel thus the
importance of serving you know it was
important if you study economics or if
you studied i'm talking about the social
sciences you really had to have a
purpose you really have to have an
inclination to serve a good cause
another thing i learned here was that
you have to learn to learn in the sense
you have to acquire critical thinking
and trying to constantly be questioning
even well establish roots and with that
i thought you know even if they don't
tell you that you will be a leader well
you learn to serve and if you learn to
learn then you want to be a leader you
have a higher probability to be a leader
but first you have to have that vocation
to serve and that humble attitude which
comes with critical thinking and an
attitude to learn or try to learn every
day you know i think
I actually think it's one of the most
remarkable things about these two
gentlemen that they have you know they
have been leaders of their countries and
yet you can see from this conversation
and those fortunate enough to take
international trade from professors a do
or faith and globalization from
Professor Blair know this that despite
years of power and despite the pattern
that many is exhibited in many former
leaders when who are much more
interested in in giving you the benefit
of their wisdom these gentlemen are
their lifelong learners you can see it
in the way they think even if you see it
in the way they express themselves they
are still puzzling out the hard
questions of today and that that's a
great virtue in a leader they presumably
led like that and they're spending their
life after being global leaders still
thinking like that still questioning
still learning still growing
intellectually it is a fabulous model
for all of us to see to see this kind of
this kind of characteristic in people
that have been at the heights of power
it's fantastic it's a great inspiration
to us all
last year I closed the one of the
question sessions with with Prime
Minister Blair with the question of
whether he preferred the Beatles or the
Rolling Stones he gave a great answer
but but I couldn't think of quite as
interesting a question to end with today
but I've got a reasonably good one it
turns out that next year Britain will be
the host of the world cup in the sport
that they call football no no South
Africa would be that pause South
Africa's the host that's all South
Africa's the host is right there at us
you guys will play that's it but the
point is the US and england you go play
in the first round and determine they
have not played in in the world in world
cup competitions since the year nineteen
fifty and of course there is one
everyone remembers that the u.s. pulled
off a great upsets of all time yes
what's your prediction for the final
score
well it's been our revenge has been
rather a long time coming oh yeah I look
forward to the to the English victory
over States of America and afterwards um
I think we should get you guys to accept
as part of the the price of defeat that
soccer is football exhaling and we agree
on that out of something absolutely well
we have to we have to get Tony back to
the UK overnight so we thank you all for
coming thank you both for participating
in this